I heard great story about you that Lorne
Michaels when you first got hired at
Saturday Night Live he heard you love
Jack Nicholson as we all do yeah we all
think he's great yeah and Lon Michael
said to you you know kid I'm going to uh
invite you over my home because Jack is
going to be over and I know how much you
love Jack and wisely and I commend you
for this you said I'm not going to your
house to meet Jack Nicholson explain why
because I I'm in full agreement with
that so it's pretty that's pretty
accurate the uh we were in uh LA and he
was having dinner with Jack Nicholson
and Jon Hamm right and he was like would
you like to come and I was like no I was
like no there's nothing I could what am
I gonna just do like you guys are gonna
have conversations about stuff you can
relate with and I'm gonna be like hey
what was the Cuckoo's Nest like you know
what I mean I I can't live with Jack
Nicholson hating me you're yes and
you're uncomfortable with being at that
dinner because you're afraid not he's
going to meet me and he's gonna [__]
hate me or he's gonna think why is this
[__] kid why is this dumb pothead at
our billion dollar table